So, here we are, back at the
prisoner's dilemma, again. You may recall this picture.
>> Vaguely.
>> Let's add to this, the minmax, or security level
profile. So, for prisoner's dilemma, what is the, the minmax?
>> Isn't it d comma d?
>> It is indeed. D comma d. Right so this
is value that you can guarantee yourself against a malicious adversary.
Malicious adversary is just going to defect on you, and the
best thing you can do in that case is defect yourself.
>> Yep.
>> Agreed, agreed?
>> Agreed.
>> Alright, so now let's take a look at the intersection of the following two regions.
There's this nice yellow region that we've already got, and
then we've got a new region that's defined by this
minmax point. This minmax profile. So the region that is
above and to the right of this, of this minmax point.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, the, that's the region. This, this region, alright we
already said that this yellow region is called the feasible region.
>> Mm-hm, or orange or whatever color it is.
>> So,
I'm thinking we can call this other region
the acceptable region. And it, and, the, what I
mean by that is if you think about
it, payoffs in this region are, smooth, getting more
than what smooth can guarantee itself in an
adversarial situation. And Curly getting more than Curly could
guarantee himself in an adversarial situation. So, these are
all, like, you know, better than it could be.
>> So, why not call it the preferable region?
>> The
preferable regions, preferable to not being in this region.
>> Mm-hm
>> The intersection of these two
Is the feasible preferable acceptable reason?
>> [LAUGH] Exactly. It's kind of, you
know, special, from the perspective that it
is both feasible and preferable. And now we are ready to state the Folk Theorem.